[Musique]
je m'appelle je m'appelle félix tremblay
géant 20 et je suis en 5éme ne sais pas
trop je pratique le hockey le golfe et
j'aime bien découvrir d'autres bref je
suis sportif de nature je suis aussi
quelqu'un de très organisé et toujours
prêt à aider les autres dans cette
présentation qu elle expliquerait les
effets positifs et négatifs de la
lumière bleue à la fin vous serez
convaincus d impact car cette rumeur
dans vos vies quotidiennes et vous serez
vous en protéger comme tu les enfants de
mon âge
en janvier dernier j'ai fait un beau
rendez vous annuel shylock de maîtrise
vous connaissez la main elle s'inquiète
toujours comme j'étais souvent que mon
ipad
mam a seulement demandé si cela avait
des effets sur la santé domicile le
problème avec l'ipad c'est l'avenir vu
qu'il reflète il ya au moins 10 % des
gens qui pensent au moins 24 heures par
semaine pour les écrans tactiles
il y en a d'autres que ces huit heures
par jour et nous les jeunes on part à
cette heure par jour
le premier rhum avoir découvert cette
lumière s'appelle une ride joseph roy il
a découvert en 1907 la force du mien
comme incassable anges mais qui t'a fait
des mélanges de couleurs de l'arc en
ciel et les formats trail pad nos
ordinateurs et sur les diodes électro
luminescentes parole peu plus à diode
électroluminescente ou comme qu'on les
appelle edel en français et les led en
anglais
elles sont haussiers tu lisais un
constant des crampes à utilisions pour
le rétroéclairage ou comme sorte
d'illumination prespa par les
télévisions à des lots c'est quoi des
loups et bien ces diodes
électroluminescentes
en organique l'amour bleus au moins 440
un homme ait un changement moléculaire
au niveau de la rétine du cristallerie
et de la cornée et chargent aussi notre
rythme circadien ce qui est notre
horloge biologique musculation les
craintes actuelles soirée troublerait le
sommet
quant à venir re est commune et comme
une lumière naturelle matinale qui comme
endormi cement elle passe aussi la
production de la mélatonine
c'est qui est une hormone sécrétée par
le cerveau qu resterai et qui baissent
le système immunitaire
quant à protéger et bien le premier
conseil que je puisse vous donner dit
d'éviter l'utilisation d'écrans tactiles
en soirée avant une heure avant le
sommet que tu aimes qu'on fait si de
petits pour lumière chaude un fonds qui
jean est amusé dans la chambre à coucher
le toit des conseils ces deux pays-là
noste de l'écrin est de maintenir le
4ème conseil si le diminuer le temps
d'exposition
si possible et le dernier c'est pour
cela qu'ils ont des lunettes
hilali verres protecteurs contre cela la
première conseil que je peux vous donner
si des prix qu'un appel soit elle et
profiter du temps avec vos amis d'aller
jouer dehors
et de là chez votre ipad
messi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]